hoch hinaus die Schweiz über 3000 Metern
wird präsentiert von Bächli Bergsport
wir leben Bergsport
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Profi Bergsteiger Stefan Siegrist und
Jonas Schild Wagen in diesem Sommer eine
Traversierung in Berner Oberland die so
noch nie gemacht wurde
eine Traversierung in brüchigem
gefährlichen Gelände
vom Lauterbrunnental ins Kandertal
11 Gipfel in drei Tagen
45 km
scheiße
bergprofi sein bedeutet auch immer
wieder neue Abenteuer liefern zu müssen
[Musik]
es ist ganz klar das Gefühl
hat würde ich sagen
dies ist die Geschichte des
profibergsteigers Stefan Siegrist der in
über 3000 Metern Höhe mit seiner Passion
sein Leben verdient sein Berg der Eiger
vor zwei Monaten Stefan Siegrist ist mit
den huberbrüdern aus Deutschland
unterwegs für ein internationales
Filmprojekt
zwei Jahre mussten sie warten bis die
Verhältnisse in der Eiger Nordwand
passen
es soll ein Film über eine neue Route in
der Eiger Nordwand werden aber auch eine
Tour in memoriam abgestürzter
Bergsteiger
und dann passiert das
Wetter
und auf die andere Seite
und die letzte Absicherung
und das hat der übereinander
Stef wollte zuerst weiter klettern nach
zwei Jahren Corona fehlt ihm ein Projekt
mit internationaler Ausstrahlung
Problematik weil ich genau war spinnst
du sowas machen
und mir zu dritt haben wir immer
gegenseitige Verantwortung und distag
mir einfach nicht Daunen sondern mit
weiterzugehen wir müssen echt aufpassen
dass nicht zu unserem eigenen memorium
Bett
Steff Siegrist hatte Glück nur seine
Lippe musste genäht werden
er ist bald 50 Familienvater und einer
der wenigen Bergprofis in seinem Alter
vor über 20 Jahren begann er seine
Karriere als profi-bergsteiger der mit
spektakulären Erstbegehungen in
Patagonien auf sich aufmerksam machte
[Musik]
er setzte neue Maßstäbe im Eis und Mixed
klettern
[Musik]
international bekannt wurde er als
jüngstes Team-Mitglied bei der Sendung
Eiger Life und immer wieder der Eiger ob
als Bergsteiger mit kletterpartnern die
Urli steck oder in der Ausrüstung der
erst Begehr
[Musik]
er erfindet sich immer wieder neu baut
sich sein Image als Abenteurer und Profi
auf lässt sich Filme begleiten und kann
sich medial vermarkten
[Musik]
inzwischen kann er gut von seinem
bergsteigerprojekten Leben
[Musik]
so hat er sich während der corona-zeit
eine eigene Studio eingerichtet da
Vorträge über seine Expeditionen rund
50% seines Einkommens ausmachen
daneben ist er immer noch als Bergführer
unterwegs und hat im Winter einen Gast
der in exklusiv Bucht
ganze wurde doch
einfach ist
das wichtigste aber sind die Sponsoren
die ihn für seine Abenteuer bezahlen
[Musik]
ganz klar da es ist aber
so ausgesprochen wird versprochen
deshalb plant Steph als Vorbereitung auf
eine große Expedition im Herbst eine
Tour in den Schweizer Alpen gemeinsam
mit dem Jungen bergprofi Jonas Schild
um die Erfolgschancen zu erhöhen fassen
Sie zwei Projekte ins Auge
überlegen
eines ist die Wand des bierthorns im
Wallis das andere ist die
grad-traversierung in Berner Oberland
je nach Wetter und Schneeverhältnissen
können Sie spontan entscheiden
beide Touren sind Erstbegehungen
warten bis die Verhältnisse passen
planen vorbereiten drei Wochen lang
haben sie in ihrem Terminkalender alles
blockiert
im Moment ja
die Tour dient Steff und Jonas als
Vorbereitung für eine Expedition am
schiffling den sie schon letztes Jahr
besteigen wollten
der Berg befindet sich in Indien und ich
ästhetisch sehr schöner Berg und hätte
Südwand oder so eine bestiege oder
begangen ist und das Gespräch wo man
schlecht abbrechen
ja
heute morgen hatten wir eigentlich
komplett die Zucker
Direktor
eigentlich gar nicht
ein bisschen das Projekt dafür erzählen
exklusiv Bilder die bisher nicht gezeigt
werden durften
es ist ein Filmprojekt das von Red Bull
unterstützt wird daneben Steff und Jonas
der Red Bull Athlet Nicola hoyak dabei
ist
mussten die Auflage eingehen dass die
Bilder erst veröffentlicht werden dürfen
wenn sie die Besteigung ein zweites Mal
versucht haben denn ein reiner
Misserfolg ohne einen zweiten Versuch
wäre für den Partner Red Bull
uninteressant
[Musik]
wie stark geben euch Sponsoren
oder Projekt es ist aber natürlich so
dass sie sagen wir helfen noch
unterstützen
marketingtechnisch brauche
und das glaube ich ist es wichtig dass
man sich nicht
helfen Sie mit finanziell sprich mit
Film mit chicos anders
zusammen mit dem Eiger sind es nun zwei
Großprojekte die nicht zustande kamen
was bedeutet es für die Tiere Situation
Erfolg nach einem anderen mit Corona
gleichzeitig kommt ist einfacher
und ich habe familiennachricht
insbesondere Vortrag machen also die
letzte Expedition erfolgreich
mit Jonas Schild ist er bereits seit
sechs Jahren unterwegs
plant seine Expeditionen inzwischen
bewusst mit jungen profi-bergsteigern
und zum zweiten ist es für mich
natürlich
ganz klar das grosses Plus wenn ihr mit
junge darf mit
gehen
[Musik]
Jonas gehört mit 30 Jahren zu den
absoluten topbergsteigern gerade in
technischen Kletterrouten
[Musik]
insbesondere wenn es
im Hochgebirge
Stef hat nicht mehr so viel Zeit um in
der Wand zu trainieren
grosser Teil ich habe die Mehrheit
voneinander
und aber er massiv mehr Erfahrung hat
und
ich tatsächlich sehr viel Kalorien und
da ist nicht
im Auto fahren
sehr klassisch wie man unterwegs ist
oder das ist das wo wir sehr feste
Schuft gefallen sehr viel strategisch zu
entscheiden und Vorfeld das ist sicher
riesen Punkt
Stef ist Vater von zwei Söhnen am
Dienstag ist der Fix zu Hause da seine
Frau Nicki als Lehrerin arbeitet
inzwischen sieht es danach aus dass das
Wetter passt und die Tour gestartet
werden kann geplant ist die
Traversierung in Berner Oberland
Wohnzimmer wann ist der
Bestätigungsmail und da draußen
in der gespaltenhornhütte und bereitet
das Essen für seinen jüngsten Sohn den
Elfjährigen Xavi vor der am Mittag nach
Hause kommt
so zum Glück haben
dank der Kinder gesehen
dafür Filme Zeit und mehr Projekt machen
viele Kollegen in seinem Alter haben
wegen der Familie aufgehört zu klettern
mit der ganzen Organisation mit der hin
dann
nicht wahnsinnig
die Frage kann ich persönlich selber
müssen stellen
[Musik]
ja es ist tatsächlich
ist eine Passion mit Risiko es ist eine
traurige Tatsache dass viele seiner
Kollegen in seinem Alter nicht mehr
leben weil sie tragisch verunfallt sind
[Musik]
auch Stef hat er immer wieder
Verletzungen Unfälle die tödlich hätten
enden können so wie an der Eiger
Nordwand
durch Kollege verloren
das ist mir natürlich lange
also der Kolleg der Julian sehr guter
Freund tatsächlich
ja
[Musik]
David Lama wo jünger ist
typisch einer von denen
und
schlussendlich ist
[Musik]
aber nicht dass man Hopfen
am Berg da muss es verdrängen
und
Unfall danke sondern
Sport machen aber sicher machen
was siehst du Niki
ja das ist anderer Punkt das wird Niki
schlaflose Nacht hat die wenn ihr
unterwegs bin
die verschiedenen
Nicki und Steff sind seit 15 Jahren
zusammen sie ist gebürtige Kanadierin
auch sie hat einen Hang zum Abenteuer
kennengelernt haben sie sich beim
Fallschirmspringen
auf der einen Seite ist es eine
Erleichterung wenn es bei Steff losgeht
und da ist immer die Hoffnung dass es
klappt
und es ist vor allem viel ruhiger wenn
er einmal unterwegs ist die Ruhe nach
dem Sturm der Sturm ist meistens bevor
er geht
viel Glück
schwimmerkrankung
besser zurückkommt ist
so
[Musik]
vom Lauterbrunnental ins Kandertal 11
Gipfel in drei Tagen
5.400 Höhenmeter in Gelände das
teilweise noch nie so begangen wurde
Konzentrationen
und ja da kommt schneller
ja es ist besitze
zudem liegt die Null gradgrenze an
diesen Tagen auf über 4.500 Metern
[Musik]
ihr Ziel heute ist die Traverse über
sechs Gipfel zum spaltenhorn auf
3.446 Metern
ein städtes Auf und Ab über einen Grad
gespickt mit Türmen voll steilen
brüchigem Fells
Schwierigkeit also das was
schön plus
[Musik]
Moment muss man aber so
kann man nicht allzu wählerisch sie
nach über 10 Stunden erreichen Sie die
schlüsselpassage den ostgrad des
gespalten Horns vor sich zwei riesige
Türme
hier müssen Sie abseilen und die Türme
durch eine brüchige Rinne umgehen danach
gibt es keinen Weg mehr zurück
nehmen
unliebsame Überraschung statt Fels nur
Geröll die spärlichen Informationen die
sie aus der Führerliteratur hatten
Stimmen heute nicht mehr
sie sitzen fest und mit ihnen auch das
Kamerateam
[Musik]
und jetzt müssen wir das kurz locken wie
es weitergeht
relativ Nass aus
die Maus
nach einer Stunde entscheiden Sie sich
doch über die Nordseite der Türme
auszusteigen
ihre einzige Chance eine Passage so
brüchig dass sie bisher noch niemand
gewagt hat
doch sie schaffen es nach zwölf Stunden
stehen sie auf dem spaltenhorn
[Musik]
sieben Gipfel haben Sie an diesem Tag
bestiegen nach 14 Stunden klettern
kommen sie in der gespaltenhornhütte an
vielleicht
[Gelächter]
aber
sehr wahrscheinlich hat die
überschritten
und
ich werde diese Sicherung nicht normal
machen
ja also zum Glück haben
mein Tag kaputt
[Musik]
morgen können wir endlich wieder
das heißt
[Musik]
wegen der hohen Temperaturen sind sie
bereits um halb drei gestartet
[Musik]
ihr erstes Ziel das morgenhorn über die
südwandrippe
[Musik]
kurz vor 9 Uhr stehen sie auf dem
morgenhorn
[Musik]
eine versteckte Perle eigentlich
und im Vergleich zu gestern
[Musik]
dank des Windes erreichen Sie die
blürmisalp auf
3.661 Metern in kompaktem Schnee trotz
bereits hohen Temperaturen
[Musik]
doch der gestrige Tag hat Spuren
hinterlassen
entzündet und aber meistens
auf dem Handy suchen Sie den weiteren
Weg Richtung früntenhorn
rund 3000 Meter weiter unten ist Nicki
mit Xavier am Schwimmwettkampf in Spiez
zweiter in seiner Altersklasse
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wieder ein Anlass bei dem Steff fehlt
wieso
Stef und Jonas versinken derweil im
Schnee im Aufstieg zum öschihorn
irgendwie
das Steff immer wieder in den Bergen
unterwegs ist gehört zum Leben von Nicki
du weißt
ob ich mir manchmal Sorgen mache ja um
alle natürlich auch im Chef
bei der Gemeinde aber die Angst ist
nicht so dass ich ihn stoppen möchte das
zu tun was er macht
oder dass es mich nicht schlafen lässt
mir ist bewusst dass ein Risiko da ist
wie in anderen Berufen auch
aber der Gewinn daraus ist viel größer
als das Risiko dahinter
für uns wäre es beunruhigender nicht in
dieser Situation zu sein das ist unsere
Komfortzone unser Leben
Stef und Jonas erreichen eine weitere
Schlüsselstelle
den Abstieg über den äußerst brüchigen
westgrad zum früntenhorn
sie haben zu wenig Seil und schlaghaken
dabei um weitere Abseilstellen zu bauen
und sicher über den Gletscher zu kommen
die [ __ ]
ja das ist schwierig zu Hause
sie steigen wieder auf zum öschihorn
gestern
ist
[Musik]
und
jetzt
so erreichen Sie auf der normal Route
nach einem weiteren 14 Stunden Tag die
fründenhütte
[Musik]
ja
ich glaube das ist
eine Situation wo wir heute Nachmittag
auf dem gratis ich glaube schon
eigentlich ziemlich die richtige
Entscheidung
einfach für neue Gipfel mehr zu machen
[Musik]
als Letzter Gipfel fehlt morgen noch das
Doldenhorn zusätzlich zu den hohen
Temperaturen ist ein Gewitter angesagt
das ist sicher schon Punkt
[Musik]
aus Sicherheitsgründen entscheiden Sie
sich für den gallettgrad und erreichen
so sicher dass Doldenhorn ihren letzten
Gipfel dieser Tour
[Musik]
Gipfel
vielleicht ist es das was denn bald
50-Jährigen Steff Siegrist
weiterklettern lässt diese Mischung
zwischen Abenteuer und der Erfahrung
nicht mehr alles riskieren zu müssen
[Musik]
Gedanken respektive ja keine große Angst
sondern ja immer das
und Besitzer funktioniert
[Musik]